Lesly Aloha are you love doing great are
you feeling good cuz you look good thank
you I'm having a blast already first of
all let's talk about this fashion cuz I
see words like Worth and courage and
strength and hope talk to me about this
special special dress yes this dress is
very special I think it's one of the
most special moments I've had on a
carpet woman and she decided to dedicate
her whole line to women who are people
who are going through mental illness
after seeing all of the things that have
happened this year especially losing
people like Anthony Bourdain and Kate
Spade so I thought it was a beautiful
thing that she did that and and I loved
the dress yeah I saw the dress and then
I saw the story behind it and I said
this is perfect because tonight we're
honoring women and their voices and
empowering them and calling them to
action to raise their voices for
something more meaningful and so I
thought it was just so perfect beauty
and brains I mean it's awesome awesome
awesome and you're right tonight is
about female empowerment I mean not only
are you performing but you are hosting
with some badass women how is that fair
like I am they're so badass I don't even
know if I'm like I'm great enough to
stand up for them I'm so excited to be
hosting and sharing the stage with them
Volodya very odd I say joseline Becky
was a great friend and will also be
performing tonight along with TN CO
vegan lick and so a lot of great stuff
is happening okay it's it's a meaningful
show it's an exciting show it's gonna be
a lot of fun I mean there's a lot going
on you know there is a lot going on you
a busy girl and you mentioned you get to
you know also share this experience with
one of your pals Becky G what's it like
to have her by your side in this crazy
journey I mean I feel like you guys are
the future of Latin music you know
it's been great to have her you know as
a contemporary person by my side we've
grown up around the same time he started
around the same time so it's beautiful
to always have somebody that kind of
gets what's going on in our lifestyle
it's not every day that you you know you
find people that do what we do at our
age so to have somebody there that
really gets it and when we do link up in
these type of award shows or video
shoots or whatever it may be we have
this sort of shared respect and
admiration and empathy for each other
that you can't really find in a lot of
places real quick what's one word you
would use to describe your performance a
first time okay yeah yeah this is the
first this is the first time we're
singing the song live ever exclusively
for Latin AMAs thank you so I hope you
guys enjoy it's gonna be great we got
some surprise I'll be talking about
tomorrow girl you look amazing - thank
you
[Music]